can you at least prevent the crash  no can you at least say the people it's  being done what happened you were reborn  you are erased from your loved ones  lives dad I don't know you no parents no  friends no girlfriend the truth is you  no longer have a home now you are ready  why am I here this is an intersection  it's an exact replication of our world  we're behind your time  but we leave you behind in everything  else we conduct experiments here  [Music]  they're saying we're 1941  there are camps  we can learn from their mistakes  just imagine there's a borderline  and it's right there and you're back  you can break free you shouldn't even  try  [Music]  [Music]  where are you going  this world belongs to me  you  you